I would say that the Democratic
candidates at this point it's president
I'm sorry you know I would say that the
Democratic candidates at this point
senator Clinton and Senator Obama have
virtually similar policies which call
for a rapid and and big increase in the
development of petroleum alternatives
and greater conservation of energy there
is no difference between them on these
issues so either one of them on these
issues in my mind would be equally
attractive I think they don't go far
enough quite personally I think they
need to go much further
bear in mind that for a dramatic change
in policy to take place we need a
Congress that is free of influence from
the oil companies and not just the oil
companies but the Big Coal and the
natural gas companies and the rest and
we're going to need a much greater
emphasis on on petroleum and energy
alternatives and without a clean sweep
of Congress we're not going to make the
kind of progress that we need so we kind
of need you know reform political reform
that's that's much broader than just a
new president and I think that's going
to take time it's going to require
political campaign reform no and there
have been efforts in that direction and
in fact senator mccain has been a
supporter of that in the past I think
he's backed away from that but he was
once a supporter of that kind of effort
we need much more of that
you